vou contar um pouco da minha história
que começa lá quando era bem novinha que
é um processo de descoberta é quando
tinha entre seis e sete anos eu já me
via correndo entre crianças de
comunidades carentes entregando
brinquedos já incentivado e acompanhado
pelos meus pais
e esse foi um processo muito importante
para mim porque conhecer aquelas
crianças me fazia sair daquele mundo que
era a escola né
as crianças que brincavam junto comigo
que estudavam comigo e eu via que o
mundo tinha uma outra percepção que eram
outras crianças que viviam talvez um duo
um pouco diferente né
e aí aos 14 anos eu já era voluntária de
algumas ações instituições de manaus
então isso é um processo que começou
desde muito pequena e fez parte da minha
adolescência então aos 14 anos eu já
participava de instituições é uma delas
já recebia portadores do vírus hiv e e
eu era um assistente administrativo na
verdade eu tirava os papéis devem tirar
poeira tentava ajudá la mas fazia mais
parte da bagunça e da alegria que era o
pessoal naquele ambiente
e aí chegou um momento que eu percebi
que quando compartilhavam as minhas
histórias as pessoas se envolviam com
elas e eu sempre escutava puxa que
bacana eu também queria lá me leva lá
pra conhecer e eu percebi que as pessoas
se envolviam bastante com as minhas
histórias e aí chegou um momento que eu
percebi que eu poderia fazer com que as
pessoas contassem suas próprias
histórias e não ouvissem sozinhas
foi aí que descobri que eu podia
contribuir para a descoberta das pessoas
porque o trabalho social ele não é
somente um processo de empolgação ele
precisa ser descoberto dentro de você né
porque caminhar sozinho até como talvez
não conseguiria chegar em algum canto
mas sozinha eu não iria tão longe quanto
eu esperava chegar na verdade eu acho
que talvez a gente nem nem
imaginava que ia chegar envolvendo
tantas pessoas né
e aí eu trago à seguinte pergunta por
pra vocês né quantos de vocês já se
sentiram motivados para fazer algo por
alguém né
ou já se sentir inspirados para fazer
algo por alguém né
e eu vou até um pouquinho mais longe
quantos de vocês já foram além dos
problemas de vocês né quantos de nós
ficamos às vezes do trânsito reclamando
meu deus que trouxe é esse que não acaba
nem ninguém vai além disso o que eu
posso fazer para ajudar a contribuir e
melhorar o trânsito então quando a gente
vê aquelas crianças um sinal há de novo
esse menino né de novas linhas entre
dinheiro e aí o que eu posso fazer com
os meus amigos está talvez não todos
porque tem certas questões que envolvem
essas situações mas não reunisse os meus
amigos eu não poderia tirar pelo menos
algumas crianças ali leva para outro
canto fazer uma coisa divertida uma
coisa legal elas entenderem que se expor
nem está nesse processo de violência de
de rua é tão ruim é tão bom tem outro
lugar né
a questão de ser motivado também ela
está relacionada com a questão do de
como eu vou te falar daquela minha
experiência né
é muito diferente chegar pra alguém
falar assim hoje é sábado passado
visitei em 11 abrigos afoita legal acho
que o pessoal ficou feliz lá é diferente
quando a gente chega com aquela época
aquela sensação de poch foi fantástico
que aconteceu no sábado passado
eu escutei histórias fascinantes a minha
vida é outra é diferente e é isso que
acontece quando a gente começa a ouvir
tanta tanta expressão na sociedade
colaborativa sociedade colaborativa e as
pessoas saem daquele sonho né
e elas acabam entrando nas ações
e essa experiência dessa ação é que leva
as pessoas a entenderem o que de fato é
uma sociedade colaborativa por que ficar
na frente da televisão né ficar
em meio a tantas redes sociais onde você
tem a possibilidade de chegar lá e dizer
poxa estão destruindo a amazônia
ok e aí você desliga o computador e
segue a sua vida nos blocos que eu chamo
do bloco do trabalho bloco da família
aquele bloco que você apenas vive ali
isolado que os sonhos não vivem né
eles estão na verdade aprisionados e
esse processo de descoberta né de fazer
algo por alguém
eu digo que é uma receita de bolo os
mais especialistas
aqueles que sabem fazer bolo dizem que
se muita gente mexer uma massa de bom
talvez não dá muito certo né
só que esse bolo aqui é diferente esse
bolo ele precisa que várias pessoas
participem dele e se descubram nele né
por exemplo o insee eles acabam
escrevendo as receitas
eu preciso de alguém para escrever a
receita do bolo né outros dizem não eu
vou comprar os ingredientes não me sinto
melhor pra comprar os ingredientes
outros dizem assim eu prefiro escolher o
recheio desse bolo
o trabalho social trabalho pelas pessoas
é essa escolha né
nem sempre as pessoas precisam ajudar da
forma que é que foi colocada na
sociedade você precisa estar no hospital
na instituição x fazendo isso insisti
aquilo mas que tal perguntar para as
pessoas e saber o que de fato gosta de
fazer né
gosta de ligar e fazer o contato para
que as coisas aconteçam é que gosta de
estar lá no dia no local no meio das
crianças no meio dos idosos numa das
comunidades carentes resolver algum
problema social voltado para o meio
ambiente político não sei mas do que
gosta
esse é o processo né da grande
descoberta que uns preferem bolos
recheados outros bolos mais simples né
isso depende muito da tua percepção de
mundo daquilo que tu acha que o mundo
precisa que pode oferecer também
e essas pessoas movidas por propósitos
coletivos ou individuais lembrando que
propósito não
se julga cada um de vocês cada um de nós
carrega uma história é uma história que
vem desde aquele momento que a gente
percebe que vida vida que o mundo é
mundo em que as pessoas precisam de
ajuda né então isso o propósito né até
porque propósito se você não tiver a
empolgação quanto os voluntários
surgiram pra ajudar em alguma ação e de
repente sumiram né porque se você não se
descobre se você não enxerga este
propósito como é que você vai dar
continuidade para aquilo
o legado é importante mas a continuidade
né
os seus projectos das suas idéias suas
ações elas são tão importante quanto e
cada vez mais pessoas se juntam o mais
importante disso é a sinergia das coisas
hoje a gente participa de grupos
voluntários em manaus onde amigos se
descobriram mais amigos pessoas é se
descobriram um em diferentes propósitos
diferentes idéias né eu garanto pra
vocês que hoje na cidade
nós temos inúmeros projetos sociais
independentes de voluntários né que
desenvolvem a cidade em vários aspectos
com várias idéias né e hoje a gente
consegue entender que ajudar ser
voluntário não precisa mais cedo aquela
ideia antiga que a gente tinha né do
voluntário que é lá daquele dia naquele
horário
com aquela obrigação hoje é de acordo
com aquilo que você entende que você
pode ajudar
se você faz uma ligação para alguém se
você ajuda a comprar os ingredientes se
você vai lá só pra mexeu a massa do bom
que a gente está montando é que o bolo
em si é ação social
você já está fazendo muita coisa na
frente daqueles que estão atrás parados
esperando
quais são os nossos limites até onde a
gente pode ajudar e até onde a gente não
pode ajudar a gente precisa refletir um
pouco mais sobre isso
os nossos limites das nossas histórias
dos nossos ensinamentos percepções
experiências
elas são muito importantes na definição
daquilo de que eu sou cidadão com a
minha contribuição com a sociedade
essa aí é acordar de manhã e trabalhar e
voltar do trabalho
está a assistir tv dormi essa minha
contribuição com a sociedade porque é
muito fácil a gente exigir os nossos
direitos né
mas assim como direitos a gente também
tem como dever e aí eu vou sugerir para
vocês algumas reflexões sobre o que é
isso é o que mobilizar pessoas pessoal a
espera é uma perda para uma sociedade
que precisa de ação imediata enquanto
você espera o mundo para né
a movimentação do mundo ela não é
somente a movimentação natural do
planeta
o mundo no move por causa da sua
movimentação natural novo mundo move
quando as pessoas se juntam naquele
conceito de sociedade colaborativa que a
gente viu quando as pessoas se descobrem
que elas de fato elas têm algum tipo de
dever dentro da sociedade
mas não é que ele dever que causa
desconforto que causa cansaço é o dever
causa prazer é saber que se eu dou eu
ajudo de alguma forma aquela forma
também consegue é contribuir não só pra
mim mas para todo mundo que tá pé
hoje a gente trabalha é incentivar seus
grupos pela cidade que já contam com
mais quase contando diversos grupos de
sua projeto sociais na cidade de manaus
a gente conta aí com cerca de 1.000
vontade né de diferentes pessoas que
contribuírem seus fim de semana
contribuem semestralmente anualmente mas
elas contribuem de alguma forma né pra
entender que a sociedade ela não dá mais
para esperar aquilo que a gente acha que
alguém vai fazer alguma hora né em algum
momento o que fazer
mas será que eu também não posso
acelerar um pouco esse processo enquanto
essa perda da sociedade que precisa de
uma ação mais imediata ela precisa
também que eu me movo um pouquinho a
outra reflexão é sobre a confiança é a
sustentação é uma sustentação da
caminhada
a confiança não é só de quem doa do
tempo do dinheiro ou doa algum tipo de
recurso a confiança também é de quem
recebe é um processo de dois lados
eu dou meu tempo né eu vou a algum tipo
de dinheiro de recurso de local eu vou
doar grupos pessoas projetos
que eu vou doar ea doação também é ea
confiança também
ela vem sendo sustentada das pessoas que
recebem porque a partir do momento que
se você que você se compromete a doar
alguma coisa né
aquela pessoa ela tem total confiança de
que ela vai receber isso de você
então é um compromisso que vale para os
dois lados não somente para quem doou
mas também para quem recebe e o
propósito é seu e como você vai ajudar é
a sua descoberta quando você se descobre
e quando você encontra o seu propósito o
caminhar pra enxergar a sociedade como
um processo de que eu posso contribuir
para que alguma coisa mude e eu parei de
está no no sinal falando
poxa aquele menino de novo envio de
dinheiro né
ou então o coxa porque esse pessoal ou
então ficar a pé
será que ele não sabe que já tem que
jogar o lixo no lixo mas será que
realmente eles receberam a informação
certa
será que a gente não pode tentar avaliar
para ver se o processo de entendimento
de que jogar lixo do chão é tão ruim
assim
as experiências e as sensações
transformam tanto quem recebe quanto
quem doa o segredo é se é a
transformação é o processo desde aquele
momento em que você se descobre né em
que você passa é descobrir qual o seu
propósito que você vai fazer na
sociedade essa experiência e essa
sensação
ela transforma tudo tudo e eu digo mais
não é preciso muito a gente já passou
pela experiência de ter dez reais no
bolso e conseguir fazer um sábado de 60
crianças hospitalizadas mais feliz
precisa de muito mais que isso acho que
não
o fato da gente ta la fae para algumas
crianças hospitalizadas por exemplo quem
faz trabalho voluntário é voluntário
apenas indo pra fazer animação daquelas
crianças às vezes nós só uso o único
mundo dessas crianças lá fora ou então
quando a gente visita uma comunidade ea
gente leva um tema voltado para a
educação por exemplo muitas daquelas
crianças têm é o primeiro contato delas
com um mundo diferente daqueles que elas
estão acostumadas do ar o tempo uma
palavra de conforto ao recurso não é tão
difícil assim pessoal
acho que basta que a gente pare um
pouquinho pra pensar é qual é o real
papel tem o real papel na sociedade de
hoje né
e aí então eu pergunto pra vocês né
é na verdade uma pergunta conjunto a
pergunta pra mim também
hoje a maioria das pessoas são meros
animais que andam sobre duas pernas que
agem baseados nos seus instintos são
pessoas que como eu falei
elas vivem dentro de blocos é o bloco da
casa o foco do trabalho é o bloco que
ela não consegue ela entra no carro ela
desce no trabalho dela sai do trabalho à
entrada de casa ela dorme
ela traz para dentro desse bloco todos
os sonhos dela traz para dentro desse
bloco os filhos tudo é muito fechado o
mundo exterior é é a televisão é a rede
social tudo fechou para aquela pessoa
isso são animais que eu não sobre duas
pernas e apenas vivem é comem porque
precisam comer dormem trabalham que
precisam pagar as contas e aí a gente
esquece que existem agora na forma de
raridade e seres verdadeiramente 11 anos
né e aí eu pergunto
nós somos animais que andam sobre duas
pernas que vivem dentro de blocos que
dentro desses blocos armazenaram todo o
seu orgulho toda o fechamento da
visibilidade de uma sociedade que
precisa de ações imediatas ou nós somos
seres humanos de verdade né e ser humano
de verdade é transformar a ação é
inspiração é trazer aquelas pessoas que
estão é somente no processo de pocho eu
queria estar lá pra fazer olha como é
que eu faço né
trazer essas pessoas para fazer trazer
essas pessoas para inspirar a fortalecer
as relações de confiança de quem faz e
de quem recebe e transformar aquilo que
seria utopia em realidade
gente muito obrigada